you get that division of like some
people will probably come out and be
like he absolutely did the right thing
america and some other people will
probably come out and be like no this is
everything that's wrong
yeah yeah oh i mean the whole world's
gonna be a mess the next episode
that's not even a shield that's that's
that black man's shield give it a falcon
quick you take it what you all saw
[Laughter]
all those videotapes they're all deep
thanks to me
they're all fake
[Music]
what's happening there reject nation got
a little bit of a scratchy throat today
we're gonna watch
new rock stars break down for falcon and
winter soldier episode four get all
those
juicy easter eggs theories and whatnot
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
falcon in the winter soldier episode 4
in which john walker avenges
battlestar's death with a punch steve
rogers bold
there's a lot of cool details in this
okay we open in wakanda
why was that woman laughing makes no
sense some b-roll she's like
wow look who's going in ballistics look
at what he's doing like no one would
react that way commentary
desensitization doesn't make any sense
okay we opened in wakanda six years ago
now this series is set
six months after end game roughly april
2024
six years prior to that would be april
2018 which would be just a few weeks
before thanos's forces arrived and
t'challa gave bucky his new vibranium
arm so bucky really had no
time to enjoy his freedom before being
dragged back into battle which is why
he's still not really okay in this
series the dora melange io does this far
outside the city past a waterfall that
could be part of the warrior falls
waterways
all to keep bucky away from the crowded
areas of the country and io repeats the
russian hydra winter soldier activation
code referenced by zemo last episode and
appearing in every episode's closing
credits
actually this episode bioactress
florence kuzumba appears right beside it
her name
translating from wakandan signaling a
crucial role in helping bucky overcome
these haunting words
i heard that sebastian stan often has
people come up to him
and they start doing that the chant oh
my god reciting it
yeah i'm sure and he punches everyone
and
he's able to get away with it starts
murdering everyone now ever since civil
war fans have looked into these words
for a deeper metaphorical meaning like
homecoming could be for spider-man
homecoming or freight car could be the
train car that bucky fell from
though the writers of that movie said
that they chose those words because they
sounded melodic and menacing in russian
but here we do get a god this is
sounding badass
could be any specific memories for bucky
furnace brings up the
hydra kernel with the red book and when
zemo used that same book to activate
bucky and berlin
all while bucky's blood boils and rage
over that brainwashing we see a
flashback on bucky's attack on howard
and maria stark specifically when he
choked maria and then the word benign
comes in with bucky trying to claw out
tony's arc reactor in the civil war
fight right before tony blast off his
arm both men
tried to render each other benign
primary weapons but the ship
does take a lot of beatings homecoming
which shows the briefest flash of
bucky's final fight in captain america
winter soldier when steve told him
give them with you to the end of the
line that was the moment steve broke
through to his old buddy and began the
long road to bringing him
home and with that the winter soldier
music that has wailed through this
struggle
give it fades away giving away to just
some simple
piano chords what a great scene what a
great performance
great and ao tells him you are free and
bucky can't even believe it he has to
look up at her to make sure she just
said that she repeats
[Music]
best therapy ever finally breathe freely
one of my favorite scenes in the mcu
ever but
maybe that's why he's so resistant
towards his actual therapist in the u.s
she needs iowa to do it for him because
like you do way too much lady all you
got to do
is just put me in front of a fire pit
yeah repeat a few words to me that i
have
intense significance and let me do the
rest it's hypnosis therapy is what he
was going through yeah but back in
latvia ayo says
the winter soldier programming was
removed from the lagarotten fur
using the analogy of shady matted fur
from a feral canine reflecting their
nickname for bucky as the white wolf
they mentioned shuri and king tachaka
and bucky says in wakandan
yeah but he can speak wakandan add that
to the list of english russian romanian
and japanese and here by calling zemo
a means to an end he echoes zemo's own
rebellion view where the ends justify
the means and loyalty to tactical allies
is not
permanent back inside zebras of super
soldiers
that warped aspiration that led to nazis
to ultron to the avengers hey those are
friends you're talking about the
avengers not the knots
yeah i love how bucky had to clear that
up but then zemo says
this the desire to become a superhuman
cannot be separated from supremacist
ideals yeah in truth the history of
american superhero comics from the 1930s
superman by jerry siegel and joe
schuster captain america by joe simon
and jack kirby
were attempts to reframe the idea of a
superman with american virtues and
patriotic colors
as a response to nazi propaganda of
white species
inspired by philosophers like friedrich
nietzsche's concept of the
ubermensch in german superman the belief
that some men can just be superior
enough supremacist man ah supremacy
johann schmidt red skull saw himself and
as they discussed this whole nazi
history and the american responses
created by jewish writers
zemo's window is segmented in the shapes
of the star of david but the important
words that zemo says
are the desire to become a superhuman
sam doesn't want the serum bucky didn't
want it steve rogers arguably didn't
really know what it was
but john walker hmm he wants it that is
the problem now bucky said for the wrong
reasons
but there has never been another steve
rogers has there
now sam might just be conceding that
steve was truly one of a kind but
sam did meet a second steve the old
steve who gave him that shield after
previous steve disappeared in the past
now it's still unclear how much society
knows about old cap like he wasn't
mentioned in the museum exhibit recap of
the in-game events and torres thinks cap
is living on the moon
whatever's going on here sam knows more
than he is telling us about that old guy
you know what's funny is that that line
that zemo says about captain america has
been one that i've seen
stir up a lot of debate so much debate
surprisingly i'm like
i suppose it can and to a certain extent
undercut the character but i think
what's so neat about this series is that
they constantly find a gray with
everything so kind of finding a little
bit of a gray
with zemo's thought process even on the
super soldiers room
yeah everyone but cap well yeah because
it doesn't necessarily
assuage all of the alliances cap has had
or the things that cap has done that
have affected the world in ways i'm sure
zemo doesn't like but i think it's just
a recognition of yeah his character as
just an individual
and plus it just made for a chilling
moment jesus guys
zemo pulls out some turkish delights
turkish delight
irresistible he uses these later to
bribe the refugee kids for info similar
to the white witch using turkish
delights on edmond and the lion the
witch in the wardrobe
by the way if you have not had a turkish
delight trust me they are very
resistant
to terrorism last episode the grc
formally began drafting legislation
known as the patch act which would seek
to restore traditional border
regulations
and fast track the return to normalcy
something
is off about this scene this weird
sounding voice over that's loud enough
to be heard by everyone but just coming
off of
whose phone there's this overhead shot
of carly standing far away from everyone
else
and then cut to an immediate close-up
where she's just sitting right among
them
and then this insert of a phone with
just a generic news b-roll no
news outlet logo yeah like last episode
i think this is another flag smasher
scene that just looks super re-edited
which i
theorize could be due to a virus-related
subplot with the flag smashers that had
to be removed
actually later in the episode there is a
similar moment with carly's big line
we separate them and then we kill
captain america
sure sure it's not unusual to show
reaction shots while other people are
talking that's basic editing especially
for nico who grew up as a cap fan and
will soon die ironically by the capped
shield but you just have an ironic
coverage for this big dramatic line
suggests that something might have been
reworked in this scene it's interesting
how they've been
really mentioning oh i don't know how
many have died which apparently last
episode according to dr nego was
tuberculosis but that was clearly an
awkwardly jammed in adr line in that
scene so yeah i have a video coming out
soon
explaining exactly what was probably
changed and what this mystery storyline
probably was
things like thinking about it and then
he tells them
turkish delight eric vassa's all one
viewer was always my son's favorite
zema lost his family in the battle of
sokovia and similarly bucky's friend mr
nakagino recalled his son's favorite
dessert
these avengers keep getting people's
sons killed now bucky's
pisses him over playing coy and sam says
he's just gonna extort you and do that
stupid head tilt thing
i love how zemo pun tilts his head right
after that now sam calls sharon carter
over
in this room he's so subtle yeah alice
in wonderland no way
no actual instagram handle for a real
atlanta artist
and this was all shot in atlanta's croc
street tunnel
power broker went in oh that's cool yeah
some publicity for you right there
you killed the golden goose magic poor
is about to get real nasty
so yeah sharon carter is not herself the
power broker but she might be working
for him like notice how she gives nods
to each of these guards she's involved
in some crime organization behind her
personal art dealings which uh by the
way
we crunch the numbers there all that art
would add up to a value of
over half a billion dollars she's not
just one person she's part of a network
actually in the past week marvel
unveiled this awesome promo website
explorematripor.com
with wanted posters for characters with
references to comic issues they first
appeared
previously on the site you can see ships
with names like mystique
and references to shanghai
what the shinji report is legit it does
support my theory that the power broker
could be connected to the mandarin or
his organization the tin rings
they hide this here i mean i feel like
it is now oh i missed those days
like the viral marketing was an
expansion of the story i feel like you
don't get them
as much anymore no not now that you have
a million like outlets of just the main
content to keep it
yeah or even the marvel one shots yeah
you know those short films
bring those back do it sharon carter
short film that will not become canon
it confuses even more power broker could
be connected to the mandarin or his
organization the ten rings
they hide the sierra at the graveyard
grandfather
who served with allied forces in world
war ii making nico grow up a huge fan of
captain america and making it tragically
ironic that cap shield
is what ends his life harley says you're
bringing it into the monument
a reminder of all the people history
just left out if anything that shield
should be destroyed
hmm you know sam suggested the same
thing last episode maybe i shouldn't
have put it in a museum maybe i should
have destroyed it
with him echoing a lot of flag smasher
talking points this episode i think it's
likely that these two are going to
partner up
now when walker and hodgkin show up they
get the attention of some they're
undoubtedly going to partner up they're
going to form an alliance they're
undoubtedly they can align with zemo
they could align with morgan
i mean come on like this episode they
were working
you know reluctantly obviously with
lamar
and john walker anytime they have to
work with them they they kind of do but
after the last episode
after walker did there's not a chance in
hell they're gonna be
working with walker after the connection
that they've had with
carly at least that sam's had with carly
yeah undoubtedly
that's that's coming now when walker and
hodgkin show up they get the attention
of some nearby onlookers who take
pictures
a reminder that everything walker says
and does in public will
be recorded notice how walker has not
shaved and that scruff just grows more
and more until it fills in the final
scene
so this guy is going rogue and he is
unhinged
wyatt russell does such a good job this
episode expressing it with all these
subtle physical tics
like when he touches his forehead again
and again as if suffering from a chronic
migraine
and then you know man wyatt russell
deserves a big respect it's pretty crazy
to know that kurt russell is in
guardians 2 as ego a wildly different
character
and his son playing an antagonist in
here as well to be able to show this
range
i don't see kurt russell when i see why
russell corrected i like you bringing it
up it's like
every time i hear that fact of like oh
yeah ego that's right it's like it's
always a memory jog like he's really
made it his own he's made a character
that even after what he did
i see it in the comments people are like
well can you blame him yeah
yeah that's the thing is like people are
debating him like and don't care about
him yeah and i mean that sometimes comes
out a little too harshly
people really beating on john walker the
character which you know
it's good he's not on social media right
now but like that's the power of a great
performance you know
yeah he's i think he does an amazing job
i love those like slowly deteriorating
being pushed on edge hyper paranoia
intense pressure type of performances
and i think he does an amazing job at
that oh yeah
it's like a young kurt russell yeah yeah
and then in the scene where the girl
leads him to the funeral watch walker in
the background right before we cut to a
new scene
he looks down and jerks his head to the
side right before the cut
now at the funeral there's a lot of
child actors and you know what that
means
looking creepily into the camera lens
roll the clip
yeah yeah little boy little boy
like did we would we not notice this
earlier excuse me carly
crushes the serum vials actually
director kari skoglyn cuts in
from below angles of that blue serum
spilling everywhere swapping in
transparent plexiglass for the surface
it's a cool visual trick that's used
in breaking bad to show the blue meth
from below but walker finds the last
unbroken vial i bet there were some
breaking bad inspiration
ah that creepy head tilt and that music
as if walker's got his own super soldier
whale
now walker threatened sam to turn zemo
over how do you want the rest of this
conversation
to go sam huh yeah
should i put down the shield make it
fair yeah look at hoskin's side eye
there
like [ __ ] it's gonna get me
killed and then when he sets down the
shield
and arises hidden in the background no
one saw this sneaky sneaky door melanche
walker insults them by calling their
vibranium spears pointy sticks
and questioning their jurisdiction as if
he has any
yeah yeah that's a great point
that's that's a miracle there's lots of
stuff we have jurisdiction wherever we
find ourselves to be
walker into the sphere that was already
thrown by the first one and then io
passes that first one her spear
and pulling out the other one's wedge
spear trading spears oh by the way
trading
spears is also what britney's dad has
been doing with the courts her money is
hers hashtag free brittany now when sam
eric beans
i watch that whole documentary don't
mock her hey no he's just throwing
support
all right and then gets pinned with his
i love that look that he gives i just
love it it's like i thought you trusted
me
you know i thought it was free yeah i
thought it was free but she calls him
james that white wolf here yeah that's
pretty crazy man
really get through to him james a little
shout out to
bost the wakandan panther deity and when
bucky pops it back on
it emits a purple glow the color shirts
black panther tech glows when it
transmits kinetic energy
also there's a bit of a hexagonal
pattern there like everything is shuri's
lab it's not me
shut up and then bucky swing you shut up
you started so much of that
jordan would go away cap's big move from
the elevator and captain america winter
soldier
and a move taskmaster will do in black
widow could taskmaster be a wakandan
no maybe it's just a cool way to pick up
a shield around vibranium
and walker wallows in defeat they
weren't even super soldier
[Music]
dude composer henry jackman brings back
the music from civil war
during cap and tony's final fight
though referencing the mexican crime
boss who tunneled out of prison via a
bathroom escape hatch and hoskins says
about the serum
power just makes a person more of
themselves right
echoing the words of dr erskine who told
steve rogers that the serum amplifies
whatever character traits that the
person has like money
and yeah just like money
power hardly who says that she doesn't
want to kill them because you're not
hiding behind a shield and then moments
later
walker enters hiding behind his shield
gun out it's actually similar to steve's
entrance with the helmet commandos in
the first cap film now when sharon calls
notice she has a bloody lip with scars
on her that's
true i figured these were from her
scuffle but it wasn't in the last
episode
but it didn't look like she had that
scene earlier
she did say magic board was about to get
nasty she might have had to endure the
power broker's wrath or
letting nagel get killed one shot wedge
is the shield in the wall still
adjusting to his new super soldier
strength now that he's juiced up and
notice how he twitches
this guy is losing control over his own
body walker growls
what's with all the knives maybe a
callback to howard stark's line the
first cap film hydra's not going to
attack you with a pocket knife walker
flings the knife off his shield
nearly killing bucky who grabs it midair
the second time
yeah in the highway chase yeah he grabs
a lot of stuff midair
do his cool nice lit move that he also
didn't win her soldier meanwhile hoskins
cuts himself free from a room
with dripping shower heads of doom just
in time
but he gets punched into a column now in
the comics the killing of walker's
parents by the watch dogs causes his
mental break but here it is a loss of
his best friend and you can see a bit of
blood trickles from above his ear as if
he's had some kind of head wound maybe
even concussed
walker jumps through the window to the
street below a reversal of cap's big
jump
up through the window in civil war
reflecting walker's moral descent
and nico yeah oh wow that's a good one
visual symbolism to finish the fight
against iron man and civil war
but whereas cap delivered just one blow
to tony's chest to de-power his armor
and spare tony's life
walker smashes it into nico's chest
again and again
true savage overkill and it is
heartbreaking to see nico a childhood
cat thing it's ironic
until the whole thing eclipses his face
in the frame and that is the last time
we see nico's face when he is alive now
this is taking place in riga latvia
actually all right let's pause for a sec
so a lot of people have been talking
about i just did like my own little
visual edit coming back and forth with
it's like a minute long between that
scene in the civil war scene with
cap slamming down the shield i'll just
play
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
you don't deserve it my father made that
shield
a lot of people have done breakdowns of
that and there's a big debate of like
it's not the same thing it's not the
same context but i would say that it's
still a
visual parallel that i think kari
skoglyn is intentionally
drawing here people are going if that
happened to bucky cap would have done
the same thing and i don't think so
i think what's demonstrating cap's
character is that he's more merciful
someone pointed out in the comments in
that video
one thing that seemed powerful about the
scene with iron man is that it looked
like he had a moment where he
contemplated killing tony because tony
was dead set on kelly bucky his best
friend yeah his lamar and i
also brought it back to first avenger
when bucky dies on the on the freight
train captain and go on
some murders
or the realities around him yeah like
this guy who did ironically tragically
die
at the hands of john walker the new
captain america he wasn't even
responsible for lamar's death
no and then walker just took it out on
him on that guy and some people are like
well there's another difference is that
walker's killing a terrorist
and that's a whole other debate because
some people side with the flag splashers
that's part of the point of the
arguments the show's bringing out
exactly first place is so that we could
be debating these things
does that make it okay though for him to
do it just because it's a terrorist
that's why i think it's so powerful
about that scene and it is
bottom line it is a visual parallel so
while the context surrounding it
definitely has its differences and i
think that's 100
valid that's what makes it interesting
is that they are different but they are
filmed in such a way that is very
evocative of each other
yeah because i don't think captain
america would have uh steve rogers would
have gone down this path not to come to
rage that way
actually that statue faced with the
three stars in the credits every episode
that's of the freedom monument in the
city of riga however they didn't shoot
this scene in latvia they shot it in
prague
that nearby statue is that of yosef
youngman czech poet and linguist who
actually created the modern czech
language
but nico dies on a nearby platform that
was constructed as a set piece
and it reads god bless latvia which is
probably built so they wouldn't piss off
local proxy
officials like beating the dude to death
on a beloved monument which
yeah this is horrific this episode is
titled the whole world is watching
a chant that we have heard with many blm
protests in the past year
and walker getting recorded is a
definite knock the countless recordings
of police brutality
keep politics out of my political
politics
keep your politics center my allegory
walker are everything
because we know from cap's exhibit that
street level imagery can get
immortalized
that photo of him using the car as a
shield in his exhibit was actually if
you go back to that first cap film
snapped by a photographer in the
background
wow what a detail his
focus goes to not even aware of what
they're staring at
until we end on the final shocking
reveal the captain america shield
covered in blood honestly more blood
than mcu titles
really ever temperature absolutely the
scarier hidden detail in the shot
look at walker's other hand it continues
to twitch
as we cut to black his inner demons are
now
believing hey by the way this is our new
anarchy assembled shirt it's available
at new rockstars
shirt and if you've been following our
weekly fitness series fitness origins
the daily workouts that tommy and i have
been doing can actually be found on the
epic hero fitness youtube channel so
that
you can join us in this journey phil
molina yes
dude posting there so yeah go over
subscribe to the channel
fitness youtube channel follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
the new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube
of everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
i just realized what did you real there
was no music throughout that whole video
i know
the music going off here which made me
realize it i was like oh yeah
yeah it's a good contrast though you
gotta you gotta mix it up you gotta
evolve the tone and style of each of
these breakdowns to keep it fresh
i think this is the the turning point
for the series absolutely episode four
this is the point of no return this is
the point where people start debating
this is the point where people
i feel like the conversations were
already happening but now with this
i'm like oh let the conversations and i
feel like there's going to be more [ __ ]
to come
i'm like what are they going to do john
walker next episode are they still are
they going to pardon him
are they just going to let him go you
know yeah
like the way how like with police
brutality how that's kind of reflecting
that
yeah you get that division of like some
people will probably come out and be
like he absolutely did the right thing
america and some other people will
probably come out and be like no this is
everything that's wrong
yeah yeah oh i mean the whole world's
gonna be a mess the next episode
that's not even a shield that's that's
that black man shield give it a falcon
quick you take it what you all saw
[Laughter]
all those videotapes they're all deep
fakes to me
they're all fake at this point
no what if the shirt does something like
that anywho guys new rocks or subscribe
to them if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects
check out our reactions hit the like
button and last but not least
jn valente judd nelson
valencia i was sitting here thinking of
a shout out for you and i was like you
know we do the name
thing and i know we've done jn before
but what does valente
mean so i looked it up and you know what
it means jan i bet you probably do
just because it seems like you know a
little bit of everything but it means
valley which is the best disney animated
film but seriously
you seem like a valiant human being this
show
is bringing up questions of valiance and
if there's a show
that we're watching right now and an
opinion about
said show that i'm not getting that i
wish i was getting there we go that
sentence is starting to make sense it's
yours
because you're quite sophisticated and
sometimes the gray areas of life that
you're parsing in your words are so gray
that i need my own interpreter to get at
them so i feel like
you would probably have some very astute
things to say about a show like this but
anyway
i just hope you're doing well wherever
you're at in the world if you see this
take care
be well and uh thanks for your
continuous support much love and we'll
see you next time